now to a major legal showdown involving
allies of former president trump the
house committee on the january 6 rights
is due to question four ex-members of
his administration later this week but
some are refusing to comply chris van
cleave is following this story chris
good morning to you well good morning at
least two of these former trump era
officials cash patel and former white
house chief of staff mark meadows have
been engaging with the committee so far
so far the key word there now steve
bannon has indicated that
he will not comply with the subpoena he
did that through his attorney claiming
executive privilege even though he did
not work for the former president at the
time of the capital attack this all
comes as the committee sharpens its
focus on former president trump's
knowledge and actions leading up to
january 6th cbs news confirmed former
acting attorney general jeffrey rosen
sat for an eight-hour interview with the
select committee wednesday the committee
has also subpoenaed jeffrey clark he's a
former top justice department lawyer who
according to a senate judiciary
committee report was allegedly involved
in efforts to overturn the results of
the 2020 election former president trump
considered promoting clark to acting
attorney general after his efforts to
investigate mr trump's baseless claims
of election fraud congresswoman liz
chaney the committee vice chair told us
the committee will work very quickly to
make sure subpoenas are enforced saying
people are going to have to appear or
they will move contempt charges against
them and in a blow to mr trump president
biden has denied his request for
executive privilege protection over
certain documents the committee is
seeking those documents could be
released next month tony
chris thank you very much